in order to maintain a trade imbalance
we know that the chinese central
government needs to keep its currency
artificially
weak and to do that they essentially can
print their currency and use that to buy
us dollars so what they do is they
increase the supply of un and they
increase the demand for dollars keeping
their currency weak now the next
question you might ask is what do they
do with the actual dollars that they
bought with the when that they printed
well they don't want to just sit on
those dollars they don't want to they'd
prefer to be collecting some type of
interest on that money so instead of
just keeping it all in some warehouse
someplace they actually just lend that
money to the u.s government and they
lend that money by buying u.s treasury
bonds by buying t-bills and
notes
so that money that they use that they
bought with their printed u n that goes
to the u s treasury
that goes to the u s treasury in the u s
treasury gives the chinese
gives the chinese central bank treasury
bonds
gives them treasury bonds so these are
treasury
bonds now what's the effect of this
clearly the bank of china is getting
interest on its money now it's helping
to finance the u.s government's debt but
maybe even more interestingly
it is creating incremental demand for
t-bonds so it is creating demand for
for t bonds for treasury bonds now what
does that do
well if you're increasing the demand for
anything that's also going to increase
the price so the price
of treasury bonds of t bills and t notes
goes up t bills are durations less than
one year but notes are durations more
than a year so the price goes up but
what happens if the price goes up that
means that the interest the interest
that the government has to pay on this
on this debt goes down
so that means that the interest
goes down and i explained that in more
depth in other videos now if the
interest goes down that means that the
cost of borrowing for the us government
goes down but that's also the benchmark
rate for the cost of debt in general so
in general it finances u.s debt both the
government and really just credit more
broadly so debt becomes cheaper
debt
cheaper
inside of the united states this is
salman khan from the khan academy for
cnbc